marie rinfret bonsoir
alors ce que vous dites c'est que non
seulement c'est mal préparés parce qu'on
répète cette phrase on était mal préparé
mal car c'est pas mal préparée on ne
s'est pas préparé pour les sécher céder
à cette paix oui en quelque sorte on ne
peut pas évaluer le risque à sa juste
mesure dans nos centres d'hébergement de
soins en procédant ou transferts de
patients des hôpitaux vers les centres
hospitaliers de soins de l'entrée à la
con
on ne plie pour acquis qu'il qu'ils
étaient en mesure de faire de la
prévention et du contrôle des infections
que les équipements de protection
à ce titre là les risques donc poser tes
maîtres et à l'essai n'est
proposé pour gérer les mêmes parce que
effectivement faut se remettre dans le
contexte de l'époque on voyait
effectivement ce qui arrive en italie
les hôpitaux des border on devait ne pas
traiter certaines personnes même s'il
fallait s'occuper beaucoup des hôpitaux
vous dites qu'en même temps il aurait
fallu quand même un plein pour
accueillir ne serait ce que des nouveaux
nouveaux résidents dans les sièges celle
dit qu'on a transféré des hôpitaux et
pour s'occuper des zones chaudes des
hongrois puis ça ce boulot c'est comme
il était absent de la planification oui
on
aurait dû parce que dégager des vies
pour augmenter la capacité des hôpitaux
un système stratégie tout à fait
convenable dans la situation
exceptionnelle que l'on disait mais on
aurait dû évaluer les faiblesses de
notre réseau des centres d'hébergement
de soins de longue durée et augmenter
leurs capacités pour faire face à ces
faiblesses tant en matière de personnel
qu'en matière de contrôle des infections
équipements de protection individuelle
vous dites on aurait dû on a sous-estimé
on n'a pas fait c'est qu'ils ont
écouté ce sens aux premières loges bien
sûr
intervenants de la santé et des services
sociaux qui était responsable de la
gestion
de cette crise d'un réseau de la santé
des services sociaux
puis quand on dit que les gens
responsables du réseau
des personnes âgées de descent
d'hébergement n'était même pas dans les
lieux de pouvoir les plus
il est plus concentré au moment de la
planification est ce que ça peut
expliquer cela bien sûr bien tu essaies
c'est là le sens d'une de nos
recommandations parce que il faut il dit
depuis la première vague des actions qui
ont été prises par
des services sociaux pour favoriser
obligé la concertation entre les
différentes directions générales au sein
d'une part la santé des sources au fait
qu actuellement les services sont
offerts de manière le scrutin au nord d
et protocole est la matière prévient des
effets ctions par et un bon vous êtes ne
pas permettre ne pas avoir permis
de que les prochains dans vienne et des
sociétés on a ajouté on a on a mis de
l'huile sur le feu
en fait et c'est une de nos
recommandations
il faut en toute circonstance même un
contexte de crise je dirais considérer
les personnes proches aidantes comme
étant des partenaires
en matière de soins en matière
d'accompagnement des personnes hébergées
en eux vu à la suite de l'interdiction
des visites une détresse des problèmes
de santé mentale vécues par les
personnes hébergées et un sens lorsqu'on
dit ce qu'on recommande c'est non
seulement de considérer les prochaines
promettant des partenaires mais de leur
offrir la formation notamment en matière
de prévention et contrôle des infections
parce que vous vous rappelez me tueur
mois on a interdit les visites parce
qu'on avait peur que des prochaines
années des personnes qui venaient voir
leur
leurs proches soient deviennent des
vecteurs mai puis bon à la limite je
vous dirai pour un court laps de temps
cela s'explique et se justifie mais à
long terme on a vu les effets
dévastateurs de cela est que les
personnes proches aidantes aurait pu
être formé pour justement offrir l uss
et contribuer à des soins sécuritaires
et humain au près des personnes
hébergées
qu'est ce que vous croyez pas ce que
vous êtes pencher là-dessus beaucoup
marie rinfret ce que vous croyez
non je vous ai amené sur le terrain mais
est clair et moi est ce que vous croyez
qu'on aurait besoin d'une enquête
qu'elles soient publiques ou pas pour
pour bien comprendre chaque millimètre
de prise de décisions au plus haut
niveau
et ou d'absence de prise de décisions
dans ce contexte
je vous dirais que
ma principale est ma première
préoccupation c'est qu'on se met en
action et qu'on règle
les constats on a énoncé dans notre
rapport
actuellement une enquête
il y a la commissaire à la santé et au
bien-être qui s'en vient et c'est dans
ce contexte de l'ocs qu'une de nos
recommandations et là dessus nous nous
innovons c'est la première fois que nous
demandons à ministre de faire un rapport
publiquement sur la mise en oeuvre de
l'ensemble des recommandations des
enquêtes qui donnent toutes les enquêtes
mais vous voulez comme si du b10 à ce
rapport clair le pot du chinois qu'on
comprendre peau claire qu'est ce qui a
été fait qu est ce qui reste à faire
pour améliorer pour que plus jamais on
laisse de côté des milliers des millions
de nos personnes âgées sans soins
absolument et ce pour les cinq
prochaines années ignoré au protecteur
du citoyen moi je m'engage à faire une
ride 50 annuel à notre rapport annuel
d'activité ce chèque actions qui seront
prises pour mettre en oeuvre l'ensemble
vous recommande bon en tout cas est ce
que ça vous a surpris à quel point on
n'a pas regardé deux bornes
oui honnêtement oui je je je été c'est
le québec on a vécu un drame
des personnes hébergées en ont vécu
dans des conditions innommables et à ce
titre lors de mon côté et j'en fait
étonnant mon rapport on a un devoir de
mémoire
envers ces personnes avaient ainsi
celles et ceux qui les ont soigné et un
sens cela dont je demande à ce qu'il y
ait des actes de commémoration pour
qu'on se rappelle et que ça nous force à
g
merci marie rinfret protectrice du
citoyen merci beaucoup nous avons